aquí tenemos un ejercicio interesante
dice encuentra a
tal que el límite cuando x tiende a 0 de
la raíz cuadrada de 4x menos la raíz
cuadrada de 4 menos a por x todo esto
sobre x es igual a 3 sobre 4 y bueno
como siempre te invito a que lo intentes
a que pongas pausa el vídeo entonces
bueno observa observa lo siguiente
cuando evaluamos el límite
superficialmente y x si x se aproxima a
cero si evaluamos en x igual a cero
obtenemos lo siguiente lo voy a escribir
acá tenemos el límite cuando x tiende a
cero lo vuelvo a escribir de 4 más x la
raíz de eso menos la raíz de 4 menos a x
todo esto sobre x ok evaluando con x
igual a cero entonces bueno tenemos aquí
la raíz de 4x pero si x es igual a 0
entonces solamente tenemos la raíz de 4
ahora acá igualmente tenemos 4 menos a
equis pero x es igual a 0 entonces
tenemos la raíz de 4 así que aquí
tenemos la raíz de 4 y acá la raíz de 4
así que esto esto es igual a 2 y también
esto es igual a 2 ahora nos queda dos
menos 2 eso es igual a 0 y x es igual a
0 entonces tenemos esta forma
indeterminada 0 sobre 0 muy bien
entonces bueno cuando tú tienes algo de
esta forma piensas en la regla del
hopital
ajá si obtiene 0 sobre 0 infinito sobre
infinito entonces tenemos aquí el límite
cuando x tiende a 0 de la derivada del
numerador sobre la derivada del
denominador ahora cuál es la derivada
del numerador bueno bueno bueno aquí
primero voy a hacer la derivada del
denominador porque bueno yo sé que la
derivada de x con respecto a x eso eso
es igual a 1 así que ahora vamos con la
derivada de él el numerador
entonces voy a derivar el numerador esto
de arriba muy bien ok entonces bueno
tomando la derivada de esto con respecto
a x tengo 4 + x elevada a la un medio
eso es igual a un medio por 4x elevado a
la menos un medio ahora la derivada de
esto aplicando la ley de la cadena lo
que obtengo es esto es más
que multiplica a un medio y que
multiplica a 4
a 4 menos a por equis aja menos por
equis elevado a la menos un medio
elevado a la menos un medio
así que bueno ya derivamos el numerador
y el denominador entonces esto esto a
que a que es igual esto es igual es
igual a algo sobre 1 porque tengo aquí
este 1 así que mientras x tiende a cero
esto es igual a 4 0 es 4 a la menos un
medio es un medio y mientras x tiende a
0 aquí también obtengo un medio entonces
bueno simplificando esto tengo un medio
por un medio eso es un cuarto luego aquí
tengo tengo a que multiplica a un medio
por un medio eso que me da eso es igual
a sobre 4 entonces más a sobre 4
lo cual es igual esto esto es igual a 1
sobre 4 pero bueno recuerda que dijimos
el problema original era que esto debía
ser igual a 3 sobre 4 entonces bueno ya
es fácil cierto a más uno debe ser igual
a tres por lo tanto por lo tanto tenemos
que a
es igual a 2 y terminamos